marijuana is one of the most popular
drugs for those who drink alcohol but
are there specific benefits or risks
when taking them together what happens
to your body and brain when you're drunk
and stoned at the same time alcohol
affects your central nervous system by
changing how your neurons communicate it
suppresses the excitatory
neurotransmitter glutamate and increases
the inhibitory neurotransmitter gaba
which causes information flow to become
slow making you feel less perceive less
and remember less weed on the other hand
contains THC which acts on the brains
cannabinoid receptors and causes some
neurons in the brain to continually fire
removing their normal refractory period
making your imagination and thoughts
magnify but because both alcohol and
weed inhibit glutamate transmission a
key part of your learning process their
combined use is linked to poor memory a
study using rats found that their
ability to recognize objects was
severely impaired when they were drunk
and high of course consuming both will
make you feel lit and studies show that
even after taking two shots the THC
levels in participants blood plasma
doubled compared to those who were
stoned but consumed a placebo drink
meaning alcohol makes you more high
participants also felt the effects of
weed more quickly and reported a better
high with a better mood and other
euphoric effects researchers believe
that this is due to vasodilation alcohol
causes smooth muscle cells in your
arteries to relax widening up the blood
vessels and an increased blood flow all
of which allows more THC to cross your
alveolar sac a part of the lung where
gas exchange occurs with the blood
ultimately the alcohol is increasing THC
absorption other research has found that
smoking dope may even reduce the damage
alcohol Dez on your liver when you drink
ethanol is metabolized by the enzyme
cytochrome p450 2e1 but after excessive
drinking this process causes oxidative
stress making cells in the liver become
fatty known as steatosis cannabidiol a
chemical component of marijuana was
found to inhibit the cycle that causes
this oxidative stress on your liver
protecting it from damage but before
this becomes your go-to party duo
consider that marijuana prevents
vomiting it's one of the reasons medical
marijuana is prescribed to chemotherapy
patients to help ease their nausea but
in the case of alcohol poisoning
vomiting is the body's way to remove
excess alcohol so being unable to vomit
poses
serious health risks curious how other
drugs affect your body and brain check
out our drug video playlist which
explains even more from the effects of
shrooms to cocaine and even coffee and
subscribe for more weekly science videos
[Music]